here's what I tweeted out the simplest
way to look at the simplest way to look
at it meaning this whole situation is
what DA's he's financially backed and
what they subsequently did to
democrat-run cities it's one thing to be
a misguided 20 year old with good
intentions it's another to be his age
with his track record and supposedly
have them too point is there is no legit
rationale for his actions unless you
want to upend Western democracies which
he's doing quite well look at his track
record and then I link to a daily mail
piece over there that has some of the
numbers that you reference Pedro is
there any version of Soros that we're
not giving credit to is he just
misguided I hear a lot of people say
well his intentions are good he doesn't
want people to rot in jail so he sends
them out onto the street right yeah he
just he foists uh rapists and murderers
on us out of the kindness of his heart I
actually again I don't I can't read his
mind uh and there are other billionaires
like him there are other
um philanthropists with you know quote
quotation marks around that word that
are doing this but Soros is just the
most notorious and I think it's just
because he's also probably the most
prolific in the sense
um it's become like his Elemental
purpose to do this but it's not just
crime obviously it's also immigration he
uses money to basically hack political
systems and and bypass the rule of law
that's why countries like Hungary have
passed stop Soros laws which are
essentially intended to to stop his
money from being used to facilitate Mass
immigration because again that's a
violation of a country's sovereignty
country for the record he was born in
Hungary that's right yeah that's right
um
no I mean you you have a guy who again
we can evaluate what he's actually doing
independent of the rhetoric using words
like democracy and openness and things
like that what is what does Soros
actually accomplish he he makes our
quality of life worse he gets people
killed he makes the United States a
place where crime has become the norm
and where we're not even allowed to
comment on it anymore because it's it's
considered a kind of anti-Semitism just
by the fact that he's Jewish